en este vídeo vamos a agarrar
experiencia resolviendo ecuaciones
radicales ecuaciones que incluyen raíces
cuadradas o inclusive raíces de orden
superior pero también vamos a intentar
entender un fenómeno interesante que
ocurre al resolver este tipo de
ecuaciones deja de mostrarte de qué
estoy hablando supongamos que tenemos la
ecuación raíz cuadrada de x es igual a 2
x menos 6 algo con lo que te encuentras
cuando resuelves este tipo de ecuaciones
es que para iniciar se trata de despejar
alguno de los radicales aquí sólo
tenemos un radical raíz cuadrada de x
que ya está despejado así es que una vez
que despeja uno de los radicales
entonces puedes elevar al cuadrado a
ambos lados de la ecuación elevemos al
cuadrado entonces ambos lados de la
ecuación reescribamos la ecuación la voy
a hacer paso a paso antes tenemos la
escuadra de x elevado al cuadrado es
igual a 2x menos 6 elevado al cuadrado y
elevado al cuadrado es una operación
válida si esto es igual a esto entonces
elevando al cuadrado esto es igual a
elevado
y este otro vamos a hacer eso entonces
si tomamos la raíz cuadrada de equis y
luego elevamos al cuadrado obtenemos
equis y esto va a ser igual vamos a
elevar el cuadro este término esto va a
ser 2 x al cuadrado que es 4 x cuadrada
4 x cuadrada estamos helando el cuadro
tanto el 2 como el x y eso le vamos a
restar el producto el doble producto de
estos términos eso va a ser entonces 2x
x menos 6 es menos 12 x x 2 es menos 24
x y finalmente el cuadro de menos 6 que
es más 36 si encuentras difícil de
entender cómo pasamos de esto a esto te
sugiero que revises multiplicación de
polinomios en particular multiplicación
de binomios donde vas a recordar que
para elevar al cuadro un binomio es el
cuadrado de este primer término menos 2
veces el producto del primero por el
segundo en este caso es menos 2 por 12 x
que es igual a 24 x y más el cuadrado
del segundo más 36 así que ahora nuestra
ecuación se ha simplificado por así
decirlo a esta que tenemos aquí veamos
qué sucede al restar x ambos lados de la
ecuación restamos x aquí y restamos x
acá
x x es igual a cero y esto va a ser
igual a 4x cuadrada menos 25 x más 36
así es que la ecuación radical se ha
simplificado a una ecuación estándar de
segundo grado y para no complicarnos
buscando una factorización o completando
cuadrados usemos la fórmula cuadrática
la fórmula cuadrática que nos da los
valores de x que son solución a esta
ecuación es igual a menos b en este caso
es menos menos 25 que sería 25 positivo
más menos la raíz cuadrada debe al
cuadrado que es menos 25 al cuadrado 625
menos 4 por a que es 4 menos cuatro por
cuatro y porsche que es 36 y todo eso
dividido entre 2 a que es 2 por 48
saquemos la calculadora entonces para
encontrar este término
veamos nuestra fiel calculadora tenemos
que calcular 625 menos 4 x 4 es 16 16
por 36 esto va a ser igual a 49 muy bien
es un cuadrado perfecto sabemos que la
raíz de 49 7 regresando entonces a la
fórmula cuadrática esto de aquí entonces
es igual a 49 y x va a ser igual a 25
más menos la raíz de 49 37 y esto
dividido entre 8 y nuestras dos
soluciones son x es igual a 25 732 32
octavos que es igual a 4 y la otra x
déjame hacerlo con otro color
la otra x que es igual a 25 7 18 octavos
y esto resulta 8 cabe dos veces en 18 y
sobran dos esto será igual a dos enteros
dos octavos o dos enteros un cuarto o
2.25 y ahí las soluciones y ahora te va
mostrar algo muy interesante que quizá
te va a desconcertar porque surge una
contradicción y de hecho te voy a
mostrar por qué surge esa contradicción
veamos si las soluciones
obtenido realmente funcionan probemos
primero x 4 entonces aquí tenemos la
raíz cuadrada de 4 es igual a 2 x 4
menos 6 la raíz cuadrada de 4 es igual a
2 y esto es igual a 2 por 48 menos 6 si
funciona 2 es igual a 8 menos 6 esta
solución es correcta probemos ahora la
otra solución x igual a 2.25 tenemos del
lado izquierdo la raíz cuadrada de 2.25
en esto no me cabe aquí de cambio ser un
poco más grande este símbolo 2.25 esto
es igual a 2 x 2.25 menos 6 ahora quizá
no puedes calcular mentalmente esta raíz
cuadrada pero si consideras que la raíz
de 225 es igual a 15 entonces podrías
deducir que la raíz cuadrada de 2.25 es
1.5 veámoslo con la calculadora para
cerciorarnos entonces calculamos la raíz
de 2.25 y es igual a 1
5 tenemos entonces del lado izquierdo
1.5 lo cual de acuerdo con esto tiene
que ser igual a 2 x 2.25 4.5 menos 6
ahora es esto correcto veamos que no 1.5
igual a 4.56 es menos 1.5 esto es una
contradicción quiere decir que 2.25 no
es una solución no cumple con la
ecuación radical por lo cual se llama
solución extraña decimos que 2.25 es una
solución extraña y aquí tenemos un
enigma porque surge esta solución
extraña seguimos todo el proceso que se
debe seguir aplicando la fórmula
cuadrática obtuvimos 2.25 donde estuvo
el problema bueno al sustituir 2.25
tenemos una pista pues obtuvimos aquí
1.5 es igual a menos 1.5 algo que
hicimos nos dio la solución 2.25 que no
aplica en la ecuación radical original
tenemos otra pista probemos las
soluciones en este paso si pruebas las
soluciones en este paso vas a ver que de
hecho
soluciones funcionan te sugiero que lo
hagas en un rato que tengas si pone la
solución x igual a 2.25 aquí vas a ver
que funciona y también si pone la
solución x igual a 4 vas a ver que
funciona así es que ambas son soluciones
válidas de esto
ambas son soluciones de esta ecuación
así que algo pasó cuando elevamos al
cuadrado que hizo la ecuación
ligeramente distinta hay una muy pequeña
diferencia entre esta ecuación y esta
ecuación y la respuesta al enigma es hay
dos maneras en que puedes ver esto para
regresar de esta ecuación a esta otra
hay que tomar la raíz cuadrada para ser
más precisos hay que tomar la raíz
cuadrada principal de ambos lados nota
que también puedes tomar la raíz
negativa nota que aquí sólo estás
tomando la raíz cuadrada principal en
esta ecuación de aquí déjame precisar
bien este punto ya hemos establecido que
tanto la solución válida como la
solución extraña de la ecuación radical
satisfacen esta ecuación que tenemos
aquí aunque sólo la solución válida
satisface
la ecuación original déjame escribir
entonces la ecuación que satisfacen
ambas soluciones porque este es un
dilema realmente interesante pues creo
que te da una idea de lo que pasa cuando
tomas la raíz cuadrada principal y el
porqué al elevar al cuadrado a ambos
lados estás perdiendo o ganando según lo
veas algo de información ahora esta
ecuación que tenemos aquí esta ecuación
que tenemos aquí la podemos escribir
como x igual a 2x menos 6 elevado al
cuadrado esta es una interpretación
legítima de esta ecuación que tenemos
aquí pero hay otra interpretación que
también es válida de esta ecuación esta
ecuación también la podemos escribir
como x es igual a menos 1 x 2x menos 6
elevado al cuadrado estas dos ecuaciones
de aquí son equivalentes pues aquí
estamos elevando al cuadrado menos 1 que
es igual a 1 así es que estas dos
ecuaciones son ecuaciones equivalentes
ahora sí reescribimos esta de aquí
distribuyendo el producto de menos 1 la
podemos escribir como menos 2 x más 6 al
cuadrado o lo que es lo mismo 6
- 2x elevado al cuadrado esto y esto son
dos maneras de escribir esta ecuación
que tenemos acá arriba cuando elevamos
al cuadrado
la ecuación original cuando elevamos al
cuadrado en la ecuación radical original
supusimos que esta era la única manera
de interpretarlo pero ya vimos que aquí
hay otra manera de interpretar esa
ecuación elevada al cuadrado
así es que encontramos dos soluciones a
esto pero sólo 4 satisface esta
interpretación de aquí y espero que
entiendas lo que está sucediendo aquí
cuando estamos resolviendo esta ecuación
cuadrática estamos obteniendo ambas
raíces aunque en la ecuación original la
ecuación radical sólo estamos
considerando la raíz cuadrada principal
otra manera de ver esto vamos a
reescribir la ecuación original déjame
reescribir aquí la ecuación original
tenemos la raíz cuadrada de x es igual a
2 x menos 64 es una solución 2.25 no es
una solución 2.25 hubiera sido una
solución también si hubiéramos
considerado que ambas de las raíces
cuadradas de x son igual a 2x menos 6
ahora ha sido pruebas 2.25
una solución válida de esta ecuación
tenemos que menos la raíz de 2.25 es
igual a 2 x 2.25 que es 4.5 menos 6
menos 1.5 esto está correcto la solución
positiva es cuando x es igual a 4 así es
que por eso obtenemos dos soluciones y
si elevan sexto al cuadrado quizás esta
es la manera más fácil de recordarlo si
eleva sexto al cuadrado y eleva sexto al
cuadrado obtienes esta ecuación que
tiene ambas soluciones ahora todo esto
puede parecerte confuso no es mi
intención de ninguna manera confundirte
la manera más simple de proceder cuando
estás resolviendo ecuaciones radicales
despeja los radicales eleva al cuadrado
resuelve las ecuaciones te puedes topar
con más de una solución sustituye las
soluciones en la ecuación original las
soluciones que no la cumplan son
soluciones extrañas en este vídeo me
enfocado en el por qué surgen las
soluciones extrañas que espero haberte
dado un poco la intuición de que la
ecuación radical se refiere a la raíz
cuadrada principal de x si hubiéramos
tomado en cuenta también la raíz
cuadrada negativa de x la solución
extraña es entonces válida